evènement [ __ ] la semaine dernière
c'était bien sûr la finale de la coupe
de france psg face à l'équipe des
herbiers
on a voulu suivre au plus près cet
événement donc on a envoyé notre pote
clément l'incrusté avec un seul défi
rentrer dans le stade de france sans
billet et serrer la main de notre
président emmanuel macron alors qu'il a
rien à faire là évidemment il a été bon
on a les images avant de l'envoyer au
stade quand même pour que clément passe
inaperçu on a commencé par une petite
séance de stylisme sont là les images
est-ce qu'on a ouais voilà petite séance
de stylisme et s'est retrouvée vide à
voir le meilleur look qui lui rappelle
celui de trouver les veines parfaite
pour s'incruster on a longtemps hésité
pour qu'ils se tassent pas griller on a
finalement choisi le même jour est que
l'équipe des herbiers ont été lissés le
plus simple il a commencé par se fondre
parmi les supporters on l'a vu pendant
un duplex sur ces news aux abords du
stade pour chauffer oui on est deux
heures et demie du coup d'envoi
maintenant ils sont nombreux les
supporters de van der vaart et le
déplacement aujourd'hui alors
certainement avec vincent et sa famille
l'ont fait des classements en ce matin
de là comment tranquille pendant qu'elle
parisien faisait leur entrée dans
l'enceinte clément il s'est fait passer
pour un membre du staff des herbiers et
il s'est retrouvé sur la pelouse
[Musique]
c'est qu'on mange pas arrangé les
ballons l'air de rien mais joue ensuite
il commence carrément à checker les
joueurs à l inde encourager pour qu'ils
gagnent 3 on sent tout le monde pense
qu'il fait partie du staff qui commence
à entraîner les gardiens carrément il
est filmé par des caméras constellé les
herbiers enfers du match malheureusement
public garder sept habituellement cp
libérés mais le seront à la fin du match
j'ai flore des herbiers et rassure son
équipe bien sûr irak royal par faire le
tour du stade de france avec toute
l'équipe et berné du peuple la laigne
chauny qui s'improvisent avec toute
l'équipe des herbiers et devinez qui
ferme la queue leu leu et basse et
d'autres témoins c'est au regard des pur
moment où le psg l'est de la coupe
tellement et même au premier rang pour
les féliciter parce qu'il est fermé il
fait pas avec tout le staff de l'équipe
[Applaudissements]
sam kd déjà ça on peut le dire c'est
qu'il a peur après qu'ils n'avaient pas
de billets n'avaient rien trouvé ils
étaient diffusés en plus sur france 2
mois ce début sur france 2 les sens les
herbiers et c'est incroyable la question
que tout le monde se pose la question
mais le président russe reste entière
clément at il serrait la main d'
emmanuel macron présent dans les
tribunes
voici les images au moment où l'équipe
des herbiers montant tribune pour
récupérer leurs médailles de finalistes
tellement mérité
tellement est là aussi justice il serre
les paluches mais cette main de la
première dame
et attention attention attention un
tacticien c'est un énorme coup de punch
et non émission la vienne pour fumer à
faire la fête dans les vestiaires
regarder cette soirée avec edinson
cavani même à celle ci avec neymar non
oh là là forcément et merci réservés
merci à l'équipe et les servir et non en
mai dernier c'est ok pas nous regardiez
électricité impossible d'être relégué
l'essai c'est très bon ils nous ont
aidés comme des malades pour qu'on
arrive à faire ça merci à tout le staff
les hommes désert le savez et aimez
merci mme holmes avec alice aller serrer
la main du président clément le serial
killer
c'est très grave quand même alors elle a
le soulève un lièvre
kamel ben oui mais voilà il a réussi
heureusement c'est clément la crue de
galère c'était sympa
[Applaudissements]
non franchement c'est comme toi un coin
a devancé un exploit tri sur la pelouse
du stade c'est fou moi même dans un
jardin public jamais je sais où